[Music]
this is just sloppy craftsmanship
rick would be excellent at biology sins
also dissecting a rodent with the garage
door open
what's with mom so you're saying that
she's acting weird on a good day
everyone acts weird in the world of rick
and morty yet still i have to ask
why is rick digging in this rat he knows
he's in a simulation he knows the rat
has sloppy craftsmanship so what is he
looking for he doesn't need more proof
celebrating math also wearing an orange
shirt and gray tie with a yellow sweater
interesting peeking into a child's
classroom window as an adult
also since rick knows morty is a
simulation why is he going through this
charade at the school
rick would immediately be getting the
nigerians to show their hands so he
could plan his escape
you know if you tell us i'll be your
girlfriend
uh you will seems like a rare
opportunity morty
simulation or not so listening sex from
a student for bribing purposes will
always be a sin take a shower with me
morty what at times like these i wonder
how the writers begin their creative
process
does it start with let's put child
nudity in this one do they have a jar
containing tiny strips of paper with
random bull
suggestions aimed at making everyone
incredibly uncomfortable and at the
start of their brainstorm they grabbed
several and slapped them together why is
this scene
lucky for us they're also really
uncomfortable with nudity i just want to
know how rick knew the location of the
school showers in the first place i go
through all the trouble of animating
this split-second peak into the locker
room and not put anything interesting in
it at all
something is drawing a lot of processing
power you have more important things to
worry about alien scum these fans aren't
cooling the computers properly they're
limping along sort of teeter-tottering
back and forth and before long your cpus
will overheat it's a real problem
trimming your nose hair while driving
i'm not sure that i can ask this
question without breaking my own brain
but
here goes why is jerry separated from
rick from the start
they're both inside the same simulation
and yet the aliens are surprised that
they've got another human they're
literally looking down on a massive
simulation with
two simultaneous simulations happening
within it there should be no surprise
that jerry's here at all
are the writers hoping to avoid
revealing the twist to us the viewers or
the aliens purposefully zooming out on
jerry's inner simulation
to rick's inner simulation forgetting
what is real at all
are we in the simulation two
i broke my brain keep your hands off
your ding-dong it's the only way we can
speak freely
because for some reason the aliens are
unable to simply listen to the
conversation
they must look and listen national apple
farmers of america
welcome to our ad agency but how would
the nigerians know this much detail
about jerry's workday when they didn't
even mean to nab him
and on top of that they only have a
simulation operating at 0.5
capacity simple question gentlemen
assuming gender
[Music]
this scene just reminds me that dave
ramsey has forever tainted the beauty
that is baker street
king dave ramsey well all is forgiven
because right now i've got an erection
the size of an east coast lighthouse hey
i'm going to make love to my wife
how big does jerry think lighthouses are
because i'm not even seeing evidence
that a pup tent has been pitched
40 relax it's just a bunch of ones and
zeros out there binary code shaming
leaving your car door open is sex really
worth giving someone the opportunity
to steal your car or running the battery
down actually yeah i guess it is but for
the principle of the matter i'm still a
synonym
making out with dead skin cells excreted
from a scalp i would definitely be on to
the simulation after seeing this
everyone knows yellow pop-tarts can't
jump depanting a child rather than
yourself
pop-tart squarepants moments ago they're
running through an alien spaceship and
quite suddenly they're racing through
another planet
we don't care about plutonians we care
about why jerry is here at all
moments ago they're running through an
alien spaceship and quite suddenly
they're racing on the moon
we don't care about the moon landing we
care about why the plutonians are here
at all
man up jerry i may need you to work the
lasers putting jerry in charge of the
lasers
doors are closing and time is running
out but the protagonist spaceship makes
it out just in time cliche
oh because shooting at the person you
want to steal information from is a
great idea
and yes this is a simulation inside a
simulation inside a simulation but the
darkness of it still matters
you simulated my grandson's genitalia
you looked at your grandson
simulated genitalia you win can we go
home now i don't know
can you grammar police sure we do it too
but we actually spent five years at
grammar police academy to get our
certification
up until now i had to brush off my
frustration with english appearing in
the alien spaceship
clearly they have their own language we
see it here and here so when the signs
were in english or the doors were
labeled i had to brush it off that this
was a simulation
and meant to continue to deceive rick
but now here in this moment before
extinction
there is no reason for we did it to
appear on the screens for our benefit
also there is no reason for this mixture
to be combined at the helm of the ship
during an office party when there are
plenty of labs up in this ship
also also rick and jerry survive this
waggling your tongue when you really
don't need to
so if you find little tiny girl balls
let me know because i'll put them right
back
up his scrotum sigerian scammers morty
the galaxy's most ambitious
least successful con artist that doesn't
make sense we're good
streaky look at that old lady she's
she's walking a cat on a leash
yes see you in 10 minutes i'm gonna go
home and sleep with my wife
and those words on your dick aren't
gonna go away unless you start using
topical cream every day
i'm a white boy but my neck is red i put
miracle whip
on my wonder bread well we're back to
our roots
driving the same streets my grandfather
started on
oh but times were simpler back then
weren't they because
people had integrity